bonjour ahmadou yéri camara merci
beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin dans
la matinale de rtl france on va parler
de la situation sanitaire en afrique ii
dans le sud de l'afrique notamment où la
situation serait critique est ce que
vous nous confirmer ce constat de
propagation du virus dans le sud de
l'afrique
oui tout à fait et surtout focalisé sur
le sénégalais dire que la semaine passée
nous avons tellement passé le seuil de
l'autre pic du gar la bonne vague et ta
deuxième paquet quelques semaines nous
observons recorder décontamination
effectivement il si celle ci avait mis
la wii développé voilà donc mon cas et
c'est c'est eh oui si juste dire que ce
sont vraiment les capitales qui sont
notre échelle atteint et il faut qu'il
se casse cette année aux origines de
l'art de l'accord qui sont des régions
qui comptent les plus grandes
agglomérations et qui sont la seule
chose de plus 20 contamination est-ce
qu'on a mené à un stade critique et à
quoi est due justement ce regain et puis
des knicks selon vous bon on parle
beaucoup de varier un deltae savez que
quand même le sénégal n'avait pas compté
beaucoup de calme après beethoven
c'était vraiment serré avec un ballon
remis mes 2 tc on n'était vraiment pas
du tout d'abord mes mails à ses
critiques parce que
voilà comme vous le savez la provocation
que on sait que valiant quelqu'un est 60
fois je souffre 62% au moins' plus
contagieux que nous voyons enfin avec
eux on ne maîtrise pas tout car le
circuit de réanimation et si nous avons
des malades qui qu'il augmente alors que
la csn et elle a en tout cas s'adapter à
la même vitesse non puisqu'on ne peut
accepter de réellement bon mais la
critique on n'est pas encore dans ma
galerie qui s'interrompt tiennent encore
le coup mais faudrait que des mesures
disent les manifestations levé cette
restriction
arrivé comme pour le dépasse à ce point
de vue alors est-ce que la vaccination
est une des clés aussi pour tenter de de
contrôler la propagation de ce virus
delta qu'en est il de la vaccination est
ce que le système kovacs a fourni au
sénégal suffisamment de l'accent corse
nationale a acheté ces doses si l'enfant
et a bénéficié de dans le vaccin sinon
pas se voir là en ce moment mais monde
au début de ce mois pour un million de
postes qu'on voit que ce qui a été le
cas et pas à l'aube à l'insuffisance du
genre et des exportations au vaccin
astrazeneca et provoque une certaine
tension comme je le dis dans les régions
surtout côtière à dakar et à thiès saint
louis et son goût la demande est très
forte et ma vision est donc ce qui fait
que
la couverture est quand même nécessaire
de -2 6% et nous attendons d'autres
bassins et vos murs entre le coup et est
du coup le sénégal veut produire ses
propres accents pour vous c'est une des
solutions
oui tout à fait vous savez le sénégal à
mon passé de production de vaccins c'est
du passé
1 2909 qui vous disais je me prenais
vaccin contre la variole
après c'était lavage d'un film sur le
site du journal jamais arrêté d'un coup
comme vous le savez la recherche
développement et quelque chose qui était
en tout cas difficile qui demande
beaucoup d'investissement et c'est le
corpus nous mettre dans la production
avec et taele les positionnements de
financement très importants comme ça
mais si tu es merci beaucoup amadou il
irait camarades nous avoir livré votre
point de vue ce matin dans la matinale
d'ayrté france